le compte à rebours a donc débuté pour
le premier ministre et son gouvernement
des 600 jours lancé dans la restauration
reconstruction du pays pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec alex lee
poulain cofondateur du média le monde
moderne bonsoir alexis poulain merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés pour
décrypter en ce discours de jean castex
ludovic de l'aer spécialiste en
communication bonsoir à vous aussi merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
peut-être une première impression
justement sur la forme vous le
spécialiste de la communication ludovic
de la r je vous l'avais trouvé plutôt
bon jean castex
je les trouvais castex sakina un peu
raide quand même et puis on a quand même
un bon padawan de la novlangue cirque on
a eu quelques expressions qui ne
voulaient strictement rien dire
notamment les députés parler des
territoires quand il parle à nouveau de
libérer les énergies
on a retrouvé du mak rond mais ont un
peu moins freluquet alexis poulain votre
avis en tout cas premièrement sur la
forme
voilà un nouveau genre en tout cas on
qui tranche avec celui d'edouard
philippe oui enfin on fait du neuf avec
du vieux j'ai envie de dire et on a
l'impression que jean castex s'amuse
découvre ce pays prend son temps et va
jouer en fait le bon flic enfin matin
c'est un peu un duo qui va se mettre en
place pour préparer la candidature pour
2022 des modèles mâcon parce qu'il est
entré en campagne et jean castex va être
le bon flic celui qui va parler aux
territoires
quand emmanuel macron n'a pas du tout
réussi et bien à recoller les morceaux à
éviter les divisions de cette france
qu'il n'a fait que diviser depuis qu'il
est au pouvoir donc c'est cette figure
là un peu rondes un peu complètement
transparente qui va permettre au
président de dérouler son programme
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs or aucun
changement de cap on reprend les idées
de la campagne de 2017
on va essayer de les mettre à la sauce
2020 pour en faire un programme un
projet de campagne sans savoir vraiment
ce qu'on va faire en six ans jours avec
moi ce qui me fait peur c'est de voir
ces gens là en charge du pays
partant de grosses tempêtes avec une
crise économique une crise sociale sans
précédent qui arrive de
d'où une crise sanitaire qui n'est pas
fini on les a vus au coeur de la crise
sanitaire
il était nul on va les voir pour ce qui
est de la crise sociale et la crise
économique qui arrive
j'ai peur qu'avec les vieilles recettes
proposées par jean castex et les
milliards qui vont être dépensées peu
importe comment le plan va fonctionner
eh bien ça ne suffisent pas parce que là
on a tout simplement il vient discours
de communication
davantage qu'un discours d'action et de
volontariat de volontarisme et c'est ce
qui manque depuis le début d'ailleurs à
ce quinquennat c'est un quinquennat de
la com et jean castex n'est n'est là que
pour faire de la com pour être cet homme
des territoires cet homme est bien dû
delà de la synthèse en une sorte de
françois hollande du maquereau nisme un
ludovic de l'air je vous vous partagez
ce diagnostic assez sévère d'alexis
poulain uniquement de la com et est
moins d'action c'est vrai qu'il s'agit
plus de territoire jusqu'à dans l'accent
alors on en a beaucoup parlé ça veut pas
dire grand chose mais c'est vrai jusqu'à
dans l'action du premier ministre on est
davantage dans la proche des régions
parlera du tournant social après mai
mais pour vous vous n'y croyez pas ce
changement de méthode vous lui
d'ailleurs par emmanuel macron est
incarnée par le premier ministre ben si
je devais y croire je serai peut-être le
seul en france 1 s'est concrètement
enfin en tout cas des gens qui
réfléchissent et pas ceux qui suivent le
goùt suprême mais j'ai pas tout à fait
d'accord avec alexis poulain en réalité
je pense que jean castex on est peut
être le temps que ça une figure ronde
il va être aussi une figure assez
implacable sur les retraites qui va
mener au pas de charge
alors effectivement avec un accent
chantant ceseda technique les maillots
lac rond depuis les parents naissance
aux poudres âge de micro communautés en
permanence donc oui là je suis d'accord
avec alexis il va cibler les territoires
avec jean castex
ils nous construisent un peu comme un
pagnol même s'il n'est pas de la
provence et c'est encore une image
d'épinal qu'on nous sert évidemment mais
par contre il va être raide sur toutes
les mesures qui doit mettre en place sur
notamment la réforme des retraites
et je pense qu'il sera même assez
violent et on aura là pas du tout quand
on parle de changement de braquet ça
fera débuter parler de ça je pense que
ça va dans le mauvais sens et que même
si jean castex dans sa carrière il faut
lui reconnaître comme une grande
compétence et savoir
vivre d'argent public donc pour ça il
est bien dans la macro ni mais par
contre il faut lui reconnaître autre
chose c'est que autour du d'une élection
qu'il a fait dans le sport effectivement
il a réussi à faire parler des gens
entre eux et d'être en permanence dans
l'apparence des consultations donc c'est
ce qu'il est en train de faire ce qui
est en train de faire avec les syndicats
effectivement dont qui les fait venir
pour faire croire qu'il leur parle mais
ils sont tous partis en claquant la
porte
donc ça n'a pas marché et puis on va
avoir oui ces deux figures qui va être
cela qui est
vous savez je crois que la présence de
jean castex et est révélateur d'une
grande crise analysé pendant de
confinement je pense qu'il une énorme
crise et que les mots ne rapportait plus
la balle à son pépère et du coup il
fallait un nouveau pour pouvoir amusé
emmanuel macron parce que c'est
totalement un homme de paille il ne
décide de rien tout est la politique que
veut emmanuel macron en tout cas la
politique constate quelle manière on
mette en place ce qui vont financer et
entièrement dans la politique sur
laquelle il a fait campagne et jean
castex va appliquer la feuille de route
souhaité par emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron raconter lui de ce côté et là je
rejoins hier alexis sur l'idée du duo va
lui de son côté jouer la fibre sociale
de la contrition tandis que jean castex
à faire le sale boulot il al'appui
l'habitude de le faire c'est un haut
fonctionnaire et de l'habitude de s'y
coller et il va le faire la file social
vous l'avez dit certains observateurs
alors pas vous aux messieurs
manifestement certains observateurs ont
pu voir un tournant social du premier
ministre cet après midi parmi les
mesures justement sociale je vous
propose d'écouter celles ci un euro a
justement pour les étudiants en oeuvre
au un repas fixé à 1 euro pour les
étudiants boursiers écouter parce qu'ils
sont l'avenir ce sont les jeunes
sept cent mille d'entre eux vont bientôt
se présenter sur le marché du travail
aucun d'entre eux ne doit se trouver
sans solution des mesures très fortes
ont d'ores et déjà été annoncées pour
soutenir l'apprentissage
il faut aller plus loin m
un plan pour la jeunesse sera discuté
vendredi avec les partenaires sociaux
première impératif favoriser l'embauché
les taille-haies de rares comme l'a
annoncé le chef de l'état avec un
dispositif exceptionnel de réduction du
coût du travail en hauteur de 4000 euros
par an pour les jeunes de moins de 25
ans jusqu'à 1,6 smic
dans toutes les entreprises et pour une
durée d'au moins un an
deuxième impératif lutter contre le
décrochage durable des jeunes qui sont
les plus éloignés de l'emploi
trois cent mille parcours et contrat
d'insertion permettront d'aller toucher
les jeunes les plus en difficulté et
5000 places de plus un service civique
troisième impératif troisième impératif
soutenir les étudiants notamment les
plus modestes qui se retrouvent en
difficulté avec moins d'accès aux petits
boulots dès la rentrée les repas dans
les restaurants universitaires seront à
1 euro pour les étudiants boursiers
alors pas donc un euro c'est et à la fin
on voit tient pas mal de mesures prévues
pour pour les étudiants alexis poule on
ne peut pas parler de tournant social
tout de même vous n'accorder aucun
crédit à ces mesures annoncées enfin
c'est pas des mesures sociales du tout
on a affaire là à un accompagnement de
crise profonde mais avec des mesures qui
rappelle en fait le cicr
ce cadeau fait aux entreprises l'idée
c'est de faire des cadeaux des promesses
de campagne de pré campagne là il l'a
dit d'ailleurs c'est un dispositif qui
va durer un an
ah bah ça tombe bien puisque après année
on va commencer la campagne
présidentielle c'est pour maquiller les
chiffres du chômage qui vont être massif
mais si vous regardez les recettes
proposées par jean castex et quoi c'est
dire aux gens de travailler plus et en
même temps et bien essayé d'intégrer des
jeunes qui vont rentrer
l'âge du travail bien fait il ya un truc
très simple évidemment oui il faut
mettre le paquet sur l'apprentissage il
faut mettre le paquet sur l'entrée dans
le monde du travail parce que ça se
rattrape pas après mai mais le logiciel
nm
on veut faire travailler les gens plus
longtemps plutôt que partager le temps
de travail pour que ces jeunes trouvent
immédiatement du travail et puis les
repas un euro c'est quoi c'est une
aumône parce que par derrière la
mentalité de ce gouvernement c'est est
de baisser les apl c'est de rendre
compliqué la vie
je me rappelle j'ai une pensée pour ce
jeune qui s'était immolé par le feu
parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à vivre ce
jeune étudiant qui n'arrivait pas
réunies qui avait 13 stades devant son
crous il ya le problème du logement
étudiant qui est fondamental qui n'est
pas du tout abordé
qu'est ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui qu'on
n'y arrive pas c'est parce que le
logement coûte trop cher c'est parce que
les transports coûtent trop cher est ce
qu'il ya des mesures qui sont faits qui
vont dans ce sens là non on va faire des
repas au resto u 1 euro ce n'est pas
assez avec l'aplomb passa du social
c'est simplement des mesures qui vont
aider les entreprises à et bien profiter
de mesures d'allègement pour embaucher
pendant un an pour que les chiffres du
chômage dans un dans un an
bien soit présentable et canal marron
puis se féliciter de son bilan fictif
c'est à peu près tout ce qui est
présenté ici malheureusement j'attendais
beaucoup plus bas dans les devis de
l'air
or justement ce tournant social on
rappelle aussi qu'à une revalorisation
de 100 euros de façon exceptionnelle de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire c'est
quand même beaucoup d'argent qu'on sort
encore et la dette qui se creuse votre
réaction
sur toutes ces mesures bah c'est de
l'argent qu'on sort effectivement donc
on sort de l'argent on va sortir deux
points du pib
les allemands sortent 20 pour sortir de
la crise voilà à peu près ce que ça
donne là la gestion de crise en france
je dis pas qu'ils allemand raison mais
en tout cas c'est assez étrange comme
comme grand écart ensuite je partage
l'avis d'alexis tout en n'étant pas tout
à fait d'accord cirque eux il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas que des cadeaux
d'entreprise les 4000 euros par une
chance
ben oui en fait c'est l'argent public
encore qu'on donne aux entreprises ça
qu'on financer des emplois et il ya
quand même sur le repas des étudiants
une problématique qui est assez
importante
effectivement les étudiants peuvent pas
se nourrir donc c'est une bonne mesure
on va qu'elle ne dure qu'un an c'est une
honte mais c'est une bonne mesure
par contre il aurait fallu gommer les
problèmes parcours c'est parce que vous
avez beaucoup de gens qui pourraient me
semble pas manger qui seront pas non
plus étudiants parce qu'ils sont
inscrits nulle part et qui sont perdus
dans les méandres de parcours sud qui
est un four absolue et stéphanie pour
revenir sur votre réflexion de l'argent
qu'on sort on sort deux cent mille euros
par mois pour une application de ce top
coville qui ne sert à rien dans lequel
il y avait un mille abonnés enfin va
mais inscrits
vous imaginez deux cent mille euros par
mois d'entretien cette application qui
ne sert à rien donc l'argent on sait le
sortir regardez les milliards qu'on a
donné à les entreprises airbus air
france pendant la crise alors qu'on n'a
pas de regret pour les étudiants n'ont
donc l'argent est versé un petit
raccourci si je peux me permettre les
devis que de l'air chaud on le donne à
ces entreprises parce qu'on espère
sauver quand même les des emplois en
tout cas j'espère que c'est l'arrière
pensée très clairement affichée par le
gouvernement tout de même d'accord sur
rien n'obligeait pas être d'accord avec
vous sinon c'est pas mal et donc voilà
c'est pas d'accord et de ce type
non mais réellement en fait on peut
donner de l'argent aux entreprises mais
il faut qu'elle n'est pas droit de
licencier derrière là il en droit de
licencier donc donc donc ça ne tient pas
la problématique en fait c'est que où je
ne suis pas d'accord avec alexis c'est
qu'effectivement ça n'est pas que la
construction d'une campagne et manu
macro ont l'habitude de faire financer
ses campagnes par l'argent public il a
déjà fait une fois quand il était
ministre de l'économie
mais là il n'y a pas que ça il ya aussi
d'aller dissoudre les républicains donc
il n'y a pas que entre guillemets un
volet social il ya aussi d'aller tenter
les républicains d'un côté leur prendre
un certain nombre d'éléments et de
déclencher des débats chez eux pendant
qu'il va se balade aux tuileries avec
madame donc oui et c'est beau c'est plus
complexe que ça et effectivement je
pense qu'il y aura certainement des
vraies mesures sociales importantes
nécessaires
il a écouté un certain nombre de choses
il a pris ce qui l'arrangeait pour
préparer ou une élection c'est vrai donc
on aura les mesures sociales pendant un
an ou deux il ya une telle casse pendant
trois ans il faut déclencher beaucoup
plus que ça alexis poulain sur la
délinquance la sécurité le séparatisme
et sami cela je mets tous dans le même
panier
plusieurs annonces aussi alors
concernant les incivilités on va prendre
les choses dans l'ordre juge de
proximité c'est l'une des des annonces
autre annonce cette fois ci sur le
séparatisme un projet de loi est attendu
tout ça c'est du colmatage
selon vous non mais c'est cocasse jean
castex rappelons le était quand même le
secrétaire général adjoint à l'elysée
sous nicolas sarkozy c'est donc un
sarkozyste qui utilise ces méthodes
et puis il faut rappeler que nicolas
sarkozy est quand même le grand casseurs
de la police de proximité qui fait qu'on
en est là aujourd'hui aussi delà de la
façon dont le lien s'est rompu entre les
populations et des policiers donc oui il
essaye de recoller les morceaux après
avoir fait des mauvaises politiques
et puis qu'est-ce qu'il fait bien il
fait comme son mentor nicolas sarkozy
c'est-à-dire pour faire croire qu'il
agit et bien il à vendre des nouvelles
lois qui ne sont jamais appliquées qui
ne servent à rien pourquoi faire une loi
sur le séparatisme quand les lois de la
république existent sont évidentes et
fonctionne simplement pour dire combat
et bien faire une loi contre le
séparatisme parce que c'est là encore
une fois un des thèmes de campagne qui
est en train de se mettre en place pour
2022 on va agiter lax sécuritaire la
division et puis faire croire que les
lois actuelles ne fonctionne pas que la
laïcité telle qu'elle est présentée ne
marche pas alors qu'elle fonctionne
alors que les lois fonctionnent
c'est la preuve une fois encore de
vraiment l'impuissance politique
actuelle et c'est pas seulement emmanuel
macron je crois que ça remonte comme je
le disais à nicolas sarkozy
l'agitation législatif qui permet
d'exister sur le plan médiatique
davantage que sur le plan réel parce
qu'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui manque en
fait pour lutter contre les séparatismes
s'ils veulent les appeler comme ça c'est
des moyens des moyens pour le
renseignement des moyens pour la police
et une véritable volonté politique
eh bien je vois dans le discours de jean
castex que les moyens ne seront pas là
et que la volonté politique est bien
elle est transformée simplement en une
énième flambée législatives qui n'ira
nulle part
ludovic adler ge balma sur ce sujet vous
savez on sentit trichez pas si ces
séparatistes ont l'islamiste radical qui
était l'urgence quand pas une seule fois
le mot femme n'a été prononcé par jean
castex pas une seule fois violence à une
seule fois c'était violences faites aux
femmes sont passées sous le tapis sur
lequel se cacher maintenant ça par
contre c'est gravissime sûr que s'il ya
bien une chose qui s'est passée par deux
choses qui sont passées pendant cet
épisode du gobi du confinement
c'est l'évidence cette femme est la
situation précarité des gens dans la rue
pas un seul mot là dessus par jean
castex sur la sortie de crise ça c'est
absolument aberrant l'égalité salariale
complètement oublié l'un c'était quand
même la priorité du quinquennat les
manuels macro enfin l'une des multiples
priorité mais s'était affichée comme la
priorité du quinquennat
pas un mot pas un seul mot vous imaginez
sire que je comprends qu'il soit gêné au
retour aux entournures avec son discours
au mas hommes avec darmanin qui a encore
une fois reconnu avoir demandé une
fellation pour un service rendu et
d'avoir utilisé son pouvoir pour ça il
est midi à l'intérieur donc son trône
qui se gêne aux entournures
mais là s'il ya bien un sujet sur lequel
on peut avoir une sortie de crise qui
aurait été honorable et surtout
nécessaire c'est travailler sur
l'égalité salariale évidence cette femme
rien rien toujours pas dit s est donc
les assauts continuent à crever parce
que il n'ya pas de défiscalisation vous
voyez le volet social en réalité et ses
angles de sécuritaires sont aussi de la
poudre aux yeux ou surtout la façon de
tirer un débat dans un sens qui va les
arranger pour plus tard parce que le
bilan de la macro ni catastrophique
absolument ça c'est certain
moi ce que je ne comprends pas et je
vous pose la question ouvertement c'est
que va à républicains là dedans
que pourquoi castex va faire ça dans
quand il joue au premier ministre et
j'imagine que que c'est gratifiant et
glorifiant et d'être heureux mais je ne
comprends pas comment est ce que les
républicains il va se dissoudre à ce
point et aller à la soupe alors que le
bilan est tellement catastrophique même
si c'est une politique de droite qui est
menée depuis le départ et d'aller à la
suite d loire philippe et il ya un des
députés aujourd'hui qui le dit assez
brillamment jean castex est condamné à
faire moins bien qu emmanuel macron
parce que s'il fait mieux
il va servir et et faire moins bien la
marge de manoeuvre reste très faible
alexis bollart votre votre réponse
justement vous vous posez les
question que les victoires oui je crois
qu'il ya une déliquescence morale
intellectuelle une faillite vraiment des
élites comme les appelle jean castex
républicaine quand on voit la
composition de ce gouvernement avec le
président de la république qui disaient
faire les bons choix et choisir les
meilleurs on est en droit de se poser
des questions en fait sur la
dégringolade en fait du personnel
politique aujourd'hui en france alors
que d'autres personnes existent sont
bien bien plus compétente et il n'y
avait pas à choisir un darmanin pour
être concise de l'intérieur d'y aller
dans ce gouvernement dont les personnes
là je pense justement que des gens les
gens aujourd'hui qui travaille avec
emmanuel macron se compromettent en sont
tout à fait conscients à la fois parce
que il ya eu toutes ces violences parce
qu'ils aient tous ces échecs politiques
et vont simplement là parce que c'est
une façon d'exister mais regardez la
façon dont a été créée la république en
marche c'est un parti qui a du mal à
s'ancrer dans les territoires puisqu'ils
la claque aux municipales fait que ce
parti a fait pschitt et qui au niveau
parisien est imparti pour en fait où
eminem la con à l'époque à recruter avec
l'ancien monsieur retraites a fait un
casting en fait de personnalités issues
de la droite et de la gauche mais qui
n'avait pas eu leur chance dans leurs
partis respectifs donc on a affaire à
des à des ambitieux à des arrivistes et
à des traîtres
ça fait un parti qui bat qui fait une
pause pique de cet acabit
malheureusement justement les
territoires on en a parlé en début de ce
décryptage c'était vraiment voilà le mot
qui revenait les territoires le local
ressouder également la france notre
première ambition sur ce point là pas de
bénéfice du doute accordée au premier
ministre ludovic de la r c'est un bon
diagnostic quand même de voir que
finalement tout le monde et est divisée
d'ailleurs ça a été assez applaudi dans
l'hémicycle cette partie du discours
oui enfin vous savez les députés en
marche lève le bras hoceinia qu'ils
applaudissent facilement mais concernant
les territoires vous savez à voir mais
je vous en parlais le jeu par le tout
cas j'aurai comme une qualité de mon
village de 280 habitants et sincèrement
le mal qui a été fait depuis trois ans
catastrophique ça quand tout tout
l'argent qui a été coupée des
territoires c'est vraiment pharaonique
et aujourd'hui tout le monde survit
comme ils peuvent
mais vraiment il ya des écoles qui
ferment c'est très très très compliqué
donc oui c'est un sujet c'est indéniable
par contre ben en fait ya rien eu
d'annoncé en réalité les cercles on a
des offres à on verra c'est important
comme on a l'habitude depuis cinq ans
donc de vue de trois ans par dont on
parle depuis plus d'ailleurs mais donc
oui moi je suis prêt à y croire ok je
suis prêt à y croire sauf que si on
regarde ce qui a été fait depuis trois
ans à chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
annonces de ce type
ça n'a jamais été tenues non jean castex
ne n'est pas selon l'article 20 de la
constitution celui qui détermine la
politique du gouvernement c'est pas vrai
c'est emmanuel macron et depuis trois
ans il fait des fausses promesses et
dans les territoires
c'est fait c'est pas un mot en réalité
c'est vraiment du quotidien de
secrétaire de mairie qui n'existe plus
et quand une mairie n'a plus de
secrétaire mais c'est sûr que c'est
assez compliqué une liste municipale et
comme des gens qui travaillent qui reste
tout les soirs jusqu'à minuit mois dans
la mairie c'est le cas le même petite
municipalité parce qu'ils font double
travail pour essayer de colmater les
brèches de partout parce que il ya plus
d'argent
les associations et des associations qui
étaient des relais n'existe plus non
plus vraiment la notion de territoire
est plus que cruciale parce que des gens
qui met littéralement il ya des gens qui
crèvent d'exploitation tous les jours
qu'ils ferment
merci à tous les deux en tout cas alexis
poulain des devis de l'air d'avoir été
avec moi pour ce décryptage en direct
sur rt france